hey cousin heard you're having money
problems no you didn't listen I got the
answer you declare bankruptcy all your
problems go away
Creed Bratton has never declared
bankruptcy when creed bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Snyder how would that help Creed
in monopoly you go bankrupt you lose you
don't go by monopoly man that game is
nuts nobody just picks up
get-out-of-jail-free cards those things
cost thousands that is a good point
bankruptcy Michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
exactly I've always wanted to be in the
witness protection program fresh start
no debts no baggage far I got my name
picked out Lord Rupert Everton I'm a a a
shipping merchant who raises fancy dogs
that's the life I declare bankruptcy
shouldn't you be taking her to lie down
somewhere
no no she ever found out that we took
her off camera we'd all be fired so just
keep taking phone calls you're doing
great three two hello again I'm Ron
Swanson and I am still taking your calls
hopefully about tonight's gala you're on
the air hi what's wrong with Joan she
has a bad hangover which she is
pretending as allergies is she gonna be
okay wouldn't know never been hungover
after I've had too much whiskey I cooked
myself a large flank steak pan-fried and
salted butter
I eat that put on a pair of wet socks
and go to sleep that works it does
please call now if you have questions
about tonight's gala or one of my other
interests Woodworking novels about tall
ships meet that sort of thing this is
Ron go ahead call her hi my Yorkshire
Terrier has chewed up the legs on my
kitchen table is there a cheap way to
repair that great question
take a walnut and rub it into the legs
of your table that'll mask the scratches
next thing you want to do is ditch the
terrier and get yourself a proper dog
any dog under fifty pounds is a cat and
cats are pointless come to the gala next
caller grapes of wrath' chocolate chip
ice cream and Johnny Cash don't trust
big banks or small banks banks or Ponzi
schemes run by morons your house isn't
haunted
you're lonely whatever happened to hey I
have some apples would you like to buy
them yes thank you that's as complicated
as it should be to open a business in
this country I've seen three movies in
my life
Bridge on the River Kwai Patton and
Herbie fully loaded my girlfriend's kids
love it it's pretty funny next caller
Ron would you like some salad since I am
NOT a rabbit no I do not ladies
I feel like all my kids grew up and then
they married each other it's every
parent's dream this just says I can do
what I want Michael what's wrong okay
wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance okay wait I thought you said
that you were hurt hey whoa Michael okay
Jim just say again really loudly what
happened you burned your foot on a
Forman grill
I enjoy having breakfast in bed I like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since I don't have a butler I have
to do it myself
so most nights before I go to bed I will
lay six strips of bacon out on my George
Foreman grill then I go to sleep when I
wake up I plug in the grill I go back to
sleep again then I wake up to the smell
of crackling bacon it is delicious it's
good for me it's a perfect way to start
the day
today I got up I stepped on to the grill
and I clamped down on my foot that's it
I don't see what's so hard to believe
about that I have to stay here answer
the phone okay could somebody come and
get me please Ryan Michael you should
stay home and rest there's no toilet
paper here could write tell Ryan to play
toilet paper can you tell them that can
you hop
I tried hopping Kevin and I bumped my
elbow against the wall and now my elbow
has a protuberance
what is going on what is going on sick
and he wants one of us to rest I'm
coming Michael I'm gonna thank you
Michael why don't you call your
girlfriend I have a girlfriend but you
said you went our Louvre this weekend it
was all made up hit the pole it's broken
right he can't Oh Dwight right oh he's
still driving too white
you forgot your bumper hello people
behead that usage report that I asked
for
[Music]
anything for you Gerry
thank you oh come on why excuse me
there's a sign at ramsett park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made Sun tea with it and now I have an
infection sir
sir are are you are you are you
listening to me sir sir I'm talking to
you sir sir are you aware that there is
waste in your water system texting
everyone hello yes I just want you to
know that this is not my decision but
from here on out we can no longer be
friends and when we talk about things
here we must only discuss work
associated things and you can consider
this my retirement from comedy and in
the future if I want to say something
funny or witty or do an impression I
will no longer ever do any of those
things
does that include that's what she said
yes wow that is really hard you really
think you can go all day long well you
always left me satisfied in smiling huh
that's what she said
ah nirvana hey guys cambree Annie Johnny
no I don't plan to buy anything here I
bite my burger and agree dance at food
and stuff a discount food outlet
equidistant from my home in my work I
came here for the same reason people go
to the zoo Shh look at that thing nature
is amazing would you like to sample our
vegan bacon 100% meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this I don't
think I can give you any more I want one
I love food and stuff it's where I buy
all of my food and most of my stuff hey
can I get these how much are they two
bucks apiece
good deal anything else nope just the
crows and the booth
you